welcome back to the 18th ever episode of
the iced coffee hour
we hope your sunday morning is going
super well
we have a wonderful guest with us today
macy
graham graham yeah thank you so much
welcome to
me thank you huge fan thank you of
everything you do i know i got my first
credit card because of you there we go
so i couldn't thank you more amazing of
course as well oh yes of course
welcome to the podcast thank you for
having me we have made
an astounding three hundred and eighty
one dollars
gosh that to four grand already yeah you
guys are catching up to me
yeah i know are we yes wow how much have
you made so far
let me see what's your total you guys
got monetized
way faster than i did we got monetized
in 24 hours it was amazing
i waited almost yeah five weeks one
second so i've made five thousand
three hundred and eighty five dollars
there we go we're catching up
yes and then let me see i don't know how
to work the app
one for this stuff quite as much um
[Music]
ten dollars ten dollars yes um
not bad ten dollars is still decent yeah
my highest cpm is in australia
of all places so mine too i thought i
think australia is one of those places
where they pay like two times
they're doing well they're kicking it
off yeah they are
yeah crazy enough our podcast has a cpm
of just under twenty dollars
wow and i think the only reason why it
has such a high cpm is because
you i think just having you and the name
i boost cpm's yeah yeah i really think
that's the case
so but andrew hales said that
doing like investing topics the video
that i did with him
yeah yeah i said hi cpm
so now you know guys just put graham
stefan in the title of all of your
videos
even if i'm not in it yeah it doesn't
just have to be about stefan no
exactly so we have actually
been making 60 and 85 cents every day
on average for the past 28 days of the
podcast nice
which is very interesting because
previously
for the for the last 28 days a week ago
it was
58.74 two extra dollars cool
and then 52 and then 44 42 and then 30.
so what are you guys gonna do with the
two extra dollars well
that's a great question i think jack is
going to lead us into options trading
because he wants to teach us how to
trade options
so this is a crash course on options
okay
cool and i know that you're somewhat
familiar with options trading
macy how much do you know um i know that
if i were to do options trading i would
be gambling that there's no point
for me before
yeah i i know that there would be no
point for me before
obviously this wonderful course that you
were providing us for free
to do it because i might as well just
take that money to vegas because that's
how unknowledgeable i am i don't think
i'm going to teach you how to options
trade but i will teach you what exactly
it is
so because people have been requesting
me to explain
what exactly options trading is i'm just
going to go straight into that
okay to me this is like the blind
deleting the blind
no kidding no kidding by the way guys
seriously i'm open-minded i'm going to
be learning as i'm explaining it
i mean i'll just put on your youtube
video how to trade options and just play
it into the mic he's going to look at
wikipedia investors just read
to be honest the way that i've been
learning options trading is just amongst
me and my friends we just kind of teach
each other as we go
so our vocabulary is not what it's
probably typically coined as like an
option strategy we kind of assign our
own
names for things so it might get a
little confusing there
but this will be a great title it's
gonna be even worse than my investment
portfolio because people are getting
upset at me for saying things like i
trusted this stock to do well
long term i trusted that this company
was going to do well and people got
upset at me for getting too emotional by
that
so with you making up your own terms i
can only imagine what the comments are
going to be on this
yeah well i think we have kind of
relatively the right terms but
what what website okay
so uh why don't we just start here what
is options trading for anyone who's not
aware
what options trading is okay in every
single options trade
you have two groups of people the buyers
and the sellers
of the options in options trading you
have two categories you have
calls and you have puts well let's
explain this what is an
option trade i want you to explain this
one option
is a contract between two people that
gives the parties the option to either
buy
or sell a hundred shares
of an upon stock at a specified date in
the future
at a specified price does that make any
sense to you mace
yeah so it's kind of like one saying oh
well i think it's going to be there
someone's saying okay well i think it's
going to be under
over something it's kind of it's over
under kind of
yes so what it is if jack has this stock
it's worth 20
right now i could say jack i'm gonna pay
you
one dollar for the right to buy this at
twenty dollars in
a year from now so if this twenty
dollars goes up in value now it's worth
fifty
then i paid one dollar to buy this at
twenty when it's worth fifty
so i make money but if it's worth less
than 20 dollars in a year from now but i
paid jack a dollar
i could say you know what i gave you my
dollar for the option i'm not going to
use my option you get to keep the 20
i'm going to lose my dollar but at least
i'm not losing 20.
exactly that's what it is and if it goes
up to 50
you make 29 because you paid the dollar
premium which offsets
the 30 revenue that you'd make between
the difference
of 20 and 50. but i make one dollar
profit yes so it's kind of good for the
both of us
and that's essentially what options
trading is but it gets a little more
confusing when you get in
terms of calls and puts because in every
option
trade every contract is not one stock
a contract will consist of a hundred
shares of a stock
so basically your profits and losses are
multiplied by a hundred so if a stock
goes above
you know if it goes up one dollar when
you're betting that it would go down
you could be losing a hundred times that
one dollar for every
dollar it goes up or down it's it's a
great idea for beginners
to do to do this yes precisely i'm 10
for 10 and i am a complete beginner
okay the last two trades i did i made 22
profit and 20 percent profit didn't you
tell me that you were
maybe gonna lose one i did tell you that
and that's because i
bought an option so you're not counting
that in the statistic
but the option is not um it has not
expired yet so this is like i haven't
lost money until i sell
right okay yes technically
it could very well be in the green and
if it goes in the green by one penny you
you know i'm gonna exercise i'm gonna
sell that option
because i don't want to ruin it what's
your total profit so far trading options
430
over how long uh it's been a few months
now three months maybe a few months
okay do you have any questions so far
options why why why options trade and
not just
invest like uh like i recommend because
if you options trade you have a lot more
choices
right you you have more options if
you're buying options you have assessed
risk
so you know exactly how much the max you
amount amount you can lose
is but if you're selling options you
have a guaranteed
amount of money that you're getting
which is the premium
which is i like that a lot so i think
what would be the most helpful thing
would be to explain the difference
between calls and puts
okay so what you're saying is if i'm
buying options
i could 100x my money basically and if
i'm selling
options then i'm getting some income for
stocks that i wasn't planning to sell
anyway unless that option uh strikes
exactly okay so to explain calls and
puts
graham do you know you know what calls
and puts out correct
so macy just interrupt me if
this gets confusing to you at all okay
so on the side of calls
you have a seller and you have a buyer
the seller of a call
will basically say that say i have a
hundred shares
of a random stock let's say sketchers
okay i have 100 shares of sketchers
and my average cost was 30 say i think
that sketchers will likely go
down a little bit or will remain the
same maybe go up a little bit but it
won't skyrocket
right say i don't think skechers will be
at 35
45 days from now okay i don't think it
will i think it could be at 32
so i sell a call i set this limit a
strike price is what it's called
at 35 dollars because i don't think it
will hit that strike price is actual
term or that's one you've made that's
the actual term
okay so that's the the price the cost of
a stock
where the the contract is exercised
got it actually essentially saying so
then somebody would look at that
and say okay it's 32 well i think it's
going to go up to 35 and they would pay
you 32.
well they would think that it would have
to go above 35 to actually have some
value
right right so if i'm paying jack a
dollar i for that
contract then it goes to 36 and it break
even
anything above 36 would make money
that's exactly it
yeah okay so that would be selling and
buying calls
okay the exact opposite would be selling
and buying puts
okay so if you're buying a call you hope
the stock goes
up right because you're paying to have a
reserved
price to be able to buy it at if the
scot if the stock skyrockets
and goes to 40 when you reserved a spot
at 35 even if you paid a little bit of
premium you're stoked
because you can make the difference
between 35 and 40
of course offset by your premium you
paid initially right
that would be buying a call buying a put
is the exact
opposite so essentially you're reserving
the right
to sell someone a stock at that strike
price
at the given date in the future how i
got started in options trading was i was
selling puts
so i was basically saying i think this
stock will go up
or down it doesn't matter but i don't
think it will go below this value
if it goes below that value i am forced
to buy it at the given strike price that
value
right i'm forced to buy a hundred shares
of that stock because an option is 100
shares
say the value is 25 i don't think the
stock will go
below 25 dollars well if it goes to 22
i'm forced to buy a hundred shares at
25.
but you already own that you're we're
talking about selling puts you don't
have to have the underlying stock to
sell a put
so i could sell a put on any stock that
i don't own
as long as i just have the cash to buy
up a hundred shares
got it okay that's depending on what
brokerage you use yes okay
yeah so some brokerages will say you
have to have the collateral you have to
have
all the money to be able to pay for the
option if it's if it goes through
um and some brokers don't really care
yeah how do they not care
how do they not where does that money
come from do you just it's like margin
okay it's margin yeah so you just delete
the app after all
very quickly yeah so that would be
selling and buying puts
got it and i was selling puts i was
saying i don't think this stock is going
to go below this value
and it never did so i was continually
just making premium by selling a put
and by acting as the insurer essentially
is what you're doing is like
how are you making premium because if i
sell a put
and i'm and i'm putting myself in a
position to possibly be
forced into buying a stock 100 shares of
a stock
at a premium price at a higher price if
i'm putting myself in that position
then someone who buys a put is paying me
premium
to be able to sell me the stock at a
premium
if the stock were to plummet the buyer
and the seller the buyer of any option
always pays the premium the seller of
any option whether it be a call or a put
will always receive yeah so it's people
just paying jack the dollar
to buy skechers in the event that it
drops to a certain price
at a higher price price right the
difference
so i sell a put at 25
if the stock goes down to 20 the person
who bought the put
would be able to buy a hundred shares at
20 and immediately sell
those hundred shares to me at 25 and
they make
five dollars per share in a contract
which would be 100 shares so it'd be 500
profit got it i just don't understand on
the puts
why anyone would do it why anyone would
sell well
yeah it just it seems like that's really
risky
it's the same thing between a call and a
put it's the exact same thing however a
call
if you're buying calls you think it's
going to go up if you're buying puts you
think it's going to go down
you're making the difference either way
it's the exact difference between
the strike price and the market value of
the stock at the date of expiration
for a strict but she's saying that why
why would someone do that
over investing their money i don't buy
options i think that's very risky i sell
options
so you recommend people instead of
buying stocks they just
they sell puts i would say my
my current strategy is not selling puts
anymore i'm doing this thing called a
short strangle
which is where i sell a put and i sell a
call
okay that's a real term
that's a real that's how i made my 22
and 20 profit was on a short strangle
so basically that means if the stock at
the date of expiration
is within two values two given values
say it's twenty five dollars and thirty
five dollars if it's within there
then i make the premium from selling the
call and i make the premium from selling
the put
because i sell the call that's the
higher you know there's the strategy
when when you're playing craps in vegas
it's called the iron cross
and it's where you bet on every single
option on the table and you basically
have
it's like an 85 chance of winning every
single time and
people wonder why don't you just bet on
everything except for the seven
because you have an 85 percent chance
every single roll not to hit the seven
well eventually you hit the seven so
eventually i think you would you would
you would win up until the point where
just one of them craps out and then all
of a sudden it's like well there's all
the prof that i made
it's gone but also it works frequently
to
roll a seven or an 11 or maybe i don't
know how to
i don't know how it works but i do well
there's that other strategy in vegas
that says you just continually double
down
i've heard of that so you go from a
dollar two four eight
sixteen and eventually what you tried to
do last time you went to vegas
which last time we went to vegas no you
were betting and then you said you were
going to turn
that 200 into a house yes no
so i was joking 100 i had 150 cash and i
said if i doubled it
13 times then i could buy it
the house i liked in vegas cash he
repeated it about five times yeah
biggest fan of an hour
it sounds easy to be like all i gotta do
is double it
13 times in a row and i and they did the
math it's like
zero point it was like six zero zero
zero zero zero zero
six percent chance of that ever actually
hitting it's not good enough so it was
like no it's like one in a billion
chance yeah
zero zero zero one two two zero
seven zero three no i think it was less
than that
that's not that's bad that's a that's a
fraction of a percent
it's ten beanies come on yeah oh no you
you
it was one two you have to divide it
once more
because it was six why because that was
12
because you have to start off at one
percent or half a percent
because if you if you have a 50 50 out
of something you start off at
half a percent yes that's why you do i
know but if you do if you do it once
more than that like divide that
by two gram that's not how you work yeah
it is that that's what the number is
you put you put point five so that's
half
your odds are always one something's
gonna happen you put it at 0.5
and then you raise it to the 13th i
think the difference is
pretty nominal between the two values i
think it's safe to say that neither
will happen neither of them is going to
happen i just want to say by the way
i i i'm going to apologize if my
explanation of
options was not very good i would like
to throw graham under the bus right now
and say that when he's explaining his
videos he gets to try a lot of times
and i don't get a try a lot of times on
the podcast yeah so if it was rough if
it was
not very clean i want to apologize know
that i am the options master
i know options inside and out like the
back of my hand and i would be able to
explain it if given more
chances too okay 10 for 10 everybody
okay 400.
so why but but you still didn't answer
why
do this the strangle instead of just
the short strangle the shirt strangle
why not just invest why not just put
your money
in a few good stocks and an index fund
why did you choose this
i like to have more control over what
i'm investing in and
there's a formula oh wait wait i swear
man how do you
not how do you not have control over
what you invest in if you could pick
like i'm investing in because there's an
assessed risk you know exactly how much
money you're putting up
in options you know exactly how much you
can lose there's
there's plenty of like there's so much
more control over what you're doing
what do you mean by assessed risk is
there something like the morning star i
think it's called morningstar review
what's that morning's
it's the morning star rating of what a
stock is and what they think of it and
they have the whole breakdown
i don't remember the psych part of that
or if it's just called morningstar is
there something
on there that firstly explain to you
this
when you invest in stocks your strategy
is to look at the financials of the
company
right yeah you look at the financials
you look at the
you look at the top leaders of the
company obviously you want to make sure
that the last ceo didn't
defraud his last company and so you do
that you look at that
you look at that you look in the news
and see what they are working on or if
they've just had a major scandal if
there's been problems with this company
in the past there's a lot of things you
look at i mean yes but financials too
but based off of the financials of a
company you know how people say that you
want to be able to buy stocks under
value
wait so you've made 430 dollars right
yes you've done 10 of these yes so how
much on average are you making from each
option
in the beginning a lot less because i
was a lot more conservative with my
trades
ten dollars no i eat
i mean i can pull it up but it's a
little bit more than eight and ten
i think my biggest trade thus far has
been i made 130
six dollars on my last trade short
strangle okay
short strangle next he's going to be
doing that
the tall strangle that sounds like a bad
name of a serial killer
so danny devito
that's terrible say that you
deem 28 as a fair price a discounted
price
for skechers okay you can sell a put at
28
and receive premium say the stock goes
down to 27
and it gets put to you and you have to
buy the stock at 28
when it went down to 27 so you're losing
100 immediately off the bat
one dollar is what you're losing but
multiplied times 100 because it's 100
shares
it doesn't matter to you because you
view 28
as a fair price for that share because
you're confident in that company you've
looked at their financials
and also even if it did go down to 27
and you didn't want to buy it you know
you're losing money you also have the
premium
to offset any loss and
in the event skechers doesn't go down
below that strike price if it goes up
doesn't matter because you've made two
hundred dollars you've made two dollars
per share so you're making a lot you're
making money if it goes up
without losing anything if it goes down
yeah it sucks because you
you lose the difference between the
market value of the share at the date of
expiration
and the strike price of the of the stock
yeah it sucks you're losing that
difference
but at the same time you view the price
that you paid for the stock as a fair
price
and you have the premium to offset any
loss
between those values so
here's my thing with it is yes when
you're
investing normally like how i do and
granted this is coming from somebody
who's
relatively like i don't know somewhere
between beginner and intermediate
i don't know i can't tell you at any
expiration date
this sounds fine until you get to the
expiration date part for me
i cannot tell you what any stock is
going to be 45 days from now that i have
you may be able to kind of guess but i i
may be able to say a range but i would
never be able to say
i know the sketches is gonna be at 28
and then it feels like you're
unnecessarily
losing money here's what jack here's
here's an example for jack
en phase it's like 70 bucks you don't
think a year from now it's gonna be at
30 or let's even say five months from
now it's not gonna be 30 right
so you're now betting you're gonna say
well not
investing saying i'm gonna sell a put
at 30 knowing that 99 chance it's going
to be above 30 i'm just going to get
free money because someone is going to
pay me
who thinks it's going to go below 30.
you have someone that's
fine too i knew end phase was uh and
here's another good one that i had sun
run i always felt like was way
undervalued and it was worth
way more than it was it was at i think
like
15 14 in june when i made my stock
market video
it's at 50 it's over 50 right now
and this is in the span of two months i
knew it was worth more but i
could never have told you it was going
to be worth 50 and that's where i find
the risk in it is i could never tell you
it's going to be at that i knew it was
valued way more and i knew that this
company had a good longevity to it but i
wouldn't be able to tell you that it
doubled
exactly so if you think if you're very
bullish on a stock and you think that a
stock is in for a big run
what you could do is buy a call okay and
when you buy a call like i said you're
paying a premium it's a premium per
share that's the max amount of money
that you can lose in this transaction
in this in this trade in the contract in
the option that's the max amount
say it was two dollars per share you're
losing 200
immediately you're paying 200 to reserve
the right to buy
this stock sun run at a specified value
let's say two three months in the future
doesn't matter you're losing 200
but how high did the stock go it went to
50 but when i bought it back in october
it was at 19.
right so say you set the call at 25
okay then you make the difference
between 25 and
50 times a hundred because it's a
hundred shares of it
so 25 times 100 that's 2 500
i hope my math is right you're making 2
500 off of losing
200 for paying for the contract if you
are bullish on a stock
very bullish like if you if you are very
confident in stock you can buy
calls i don't recommend it i'm
personally not someone who buys options
i like to sell them
but you could buy calls if you think a
stock will skyrocket and you can buy
puts
if you think a stock will plummet you
always make the difference between the
strike
price and mark how much could i make if
if i have like 60 grand worth of boeing
how much can i make because i'm let's
say i have 100 shares of boeing
uh i don't know what that would be a
hundred and something thousand dollars
of boeing
um how much would i make selling
selling a put no you'd right if you have
the stock you'd want to sell a call
which means that selling calls is
actually one of the
the most conservative ways that you can
make money there's very low risk in
selling calls
as long as you have the underlying stock
so what's bowing at right now
uh what is it 160 160 okay say you sell
a call
at 180 okay that means that you're
forced
to sell 100 shares of that stock at 180
at a specified date in the future sorry
you're not forced
but the person who bought the call has
the option to buy it at once
so if it goes below they're obviously
not going to buy it at 180 and if it
goes above they will buy it at 180.
right but how much what's the premium
what can i expect yeah on a covered call
at 180
yeah for boeing how long in the future
yeah let's yeah let's look it up let's
click the cameras off and on i'm curious
all right so yeah 100 shares of boeing
so when do you want to set the x the
date of expiration when do you want the
contract to be done
next month next month so let's say
october 16th
sure okay october 16th if you're selling
a call
at 180 you can make four dollars and 53
cents per share so 453
and if it doesn't go to 180 you just get
453 dollars
if it goes above then yeah you have to
sell it 180 but you're still making
profit on this
so yeah so i'm investing let's say 16
300 in boeing to make
400 in a month if the stock price
stays below 180
yes yeah but also if the stock goes
to 180 453 you're breaking even
because you're gaining 453 per share
right
so if you think boeing is going to be at
basically 185 or higher
by october 16th it wouldn't be a good
idea
but also you still are going to be
selling the stock for a profit
right because i'm sure that you bought
the stock at a cheaper price right
you're selling it for a profit
and you're still making 453 dollars so
i got this here my it's called options
train on schwab
that's the options chain yeah and uh
so we're right here so
180 what is this bid and ask 16.50 and
17
so this would be a put and that's a call
this is the call side and that's the put
side yeah and then this would be
the prices of selling and buying
about 465 dollars
if you did it right here at 165 you'd
make a thousand basically
which is pretty cool making a thousand
dollars immediately obviously if it goes
down you have to hold on to the stock
and
it will depreciate and you'll lose value
that way but you also have a
9.45 cents to offset any loss if it were
to go down
interesting so that's where you get the
control factor
in trading options you know basically
what you could lose
what you could gain and also when you
are in a contract this is the good part
when you're in a contract you don't have
to wait until
expiration you don't have to wait
because that contract is what holds the
value
if you buy a call you can sell that
contract
short of term like you can sell it
before
it expires if i'm selling a put right
which is when you hope the stock doesn't
go down because then you'd be forced to
buy it at a higher price
if the stock starts to go down a little
bit and i'm like whoa
i don't i don't want to have the pot you
know potentially buy this stock
at a really high price what i could do
is i could just do this
thing called buy back which means i
would um
put my contract that i had up onto the
market and then people would buy the
contract away from me
and the short strangles let me explain
to you why they
are good why i like them if the stock
goes up
and you're forced to sell 100 shares of
that stock
right because if it's a covered call
you're forced if it goes up you're
forced to
sell at a lower price than what it is
you're going to have the premium you cut
collect from the call and the premium
you collect from the put to offset that
if it goes down and you're forced to buy
from
you know selling the put you're forced
to buy you have the premium from the
call
and the put that you have to offset that
so it's just as long as it remains
between two values you have both the
premium
from the call and the put to offset any
crazy jump if it were
by any chance to go outside of this
range of values that you set
you don't view options as being a quick
money grab on a lot of these i saw a lot
of clearly not i've made four hundred
dollars in three months well you're
making that
short term but i think that's funny but
i've seen
a lot of people who have commented or
have talked about their tesla shares and
how they were
doing options on it when everything was
going down i've made
like 10 000 off of my tesla
and me putting that money there and a
lot of the people that are doing options
they made a thousand
but they weren't able to hold it long
enough
or whatever they didn't have the value
in there for it to
i don't i don't know they didn't hold it
long enough they were doing these option
trades for super short curls i don't buy
options i sell them buying options is
very risky
you can make a lot of that's all the
yolos on wall street bets that's buying
options
if you've ever heard of theta gang
that's like the opposite of wall street
bets
those are the people that take a lot
more time in their trades
at least i think i'm not very familiar
with data gang i peruse you know
but they sell options ver it's a smaller
community a lot smaller community
theta gang sells wall street bets the
yolos where you have crazy gains and
crazy losses those are all people buying
calls and puts
expecting a spot stock to plummet or to
skyrocket
got it okay so those are the people that
are saying options
traded tesla yeah i was doing options on
tesla i should have just held
the what people think of when you say
you're doing options trading and they go
oh my gosh
you're gambling yeah you're getting it's
they're probably
thinking about buying options you know
how like when you say you're doing
options like there's kind of a stigma
around it like you're doing really risky
investments
you are if you're buying in my opinion
of course i may not be right but this is
what a lot of people think
if you're buying options yeah it's a
total risk it's a gamble
but what's the who's the person
transacting with that person
got it they have to transact with one
another you have one person taking big
risks the gambler
you have one person that's transacting
with that person selling
is transacting with the gambler buying
is being the gambler in my opinion yeah
i still think for most people though it
would be a gamble
i know that sounds a little bit
contrarian to what you just said but i
think
even myself i would not feel comfortable
doing it no matter how much i learn
on all this because i still feel i don't
know enough for it
to be such a big risk i might as well be
gambling macy
if you want i encourage you to look into
it i would have to know more
when i'm looking at stocks i know
specifically what i'm looking for
long term looking for something and what
i'm talking about long term i mean years
in the future
so i would need to look into this more
but it's definitely something i'm open
to learning more about and
learning because there's one thing to
understand the concept and then it's
another thing
to actually do it if that makes sense so
i would need to know what i'm looking
for when actually doing it versus just
understanding the concepts
that's fair i still i'm not a hundred
percent certain of what i'm doing i'm
learning
i don't know i'm getting no it's no i
love it honestly like i'm getting more
and more sure of myself the more that i
do it
like i tried day trading i only lost
money like i really i had a hard time
day trading it was terrible
he bought tesla we gotta
know yeah oh yeah i posted on my
instagram the people
on my instagram the only reason tesla
went down was because you bought it yeah
elon musk was waiting is like okay
jackbot sell
here i'll uh um check this out i'll take
a screenshot and just like
throw this up this is my robinhood
account okay
right this is a little bit of my play
money so this is when i got all the free
stocks
and they just kind of appreciate it a
little bit thank you graham for using my
referral link
um so they appreciate it i was making
money i was like okay that's sick i
started day trading right here
oh basically only losses okay
[Laughter]
you should tell us when you're buying so
we sell i lost
200 day trading and i was extremely
frustrated
to say the least so i was like i'm sick
of waking up at 6 30 in the morning
to lose money and to walk downstairs and
tell my dad yeah we had a red day
but that's what happened and i basically
just held cash in my account for right
here
okay i was like i'm sick and tired of
losing money waking up at 6 a.m
i'm holding cash guess when i decided to
just buy
spy oh my goodness
wow your timing is terrible okay so he
was up for like a day
i realized it makes no sense to hold you
know this money in my account
might as well just hold sby right just
get sp why because it will grow over
time
i bought right here plummeted and i was
so fr i was like what am i only losing
money
right and then i decided i'm going to
start selling options
consistent gains over time and then
right here
bought tesla stock but i'm just saying
you started buying and started doing
options
why can't okay uh march 23rd
that was the market bottom seventy eight
hundred yeah questions
weren't really directional they weren't
really i know but had you just
invested all of that or just kept your
investment here that's what i bought
tesla eight okay wait
wait wait so 8 000 that was what
february what date was that
that was march 20th i started doing
options it was yeah it was like
it was probably march 30th so
graham said he was willing to yolo some
money into the market a thousand dollars
to be specific
the best way we can yolo your money of
course would not be selling options it
would be buying options sure
so what do you want to do do you want to
pick a stock that you're really bullish
on
we can buy a call would you want to pick
a stock that you're very bearish on you
think it's going to plummet
we could buy a put or do you want to
leave it up
to them to find they're going to pick
something crazy that's going to lose
money i really want to do the snowflake
ipo
i really want to buy calls on that you
don't want to ask questions
if anything wouldn't you want to buy
puts why in short term
no no long term puts or you could do
short term calls
if you think because it's gonna go up
yeah i think it's gonna go for like two
days can i do like two days
you could do a week out call probably if
they do i don't even i don't even think
i could do
snow right now let's see it's not even
available on robin hood
yes it's too early some stocks don't
have options
tesla fantastic it's always tesla man
why is tesla i probably wouldn't do that
why are you
because that's this friday you think
tesla's gonna go about 475 by this
friday what's it at right now 446.
it's a thousand bucks let's just try it
really yeah it's
at almost 450. so wait oh so i'm only
buying one contract
worst case scenario you could just sell
the option oh
it's a thousand bucks this is for
content
he needs to write off you know how when
we had her on the podcast last time we
titled it graham makes the riskiest
investment of his life when he's
invested in dogecoin
what's up with her coming on the podcast
are you making these
dogecoin was stupid at least with 10 at
least with tesla
at 475 i think is is reasonable for the
stock it's just it's so unpredictable
okay you don't want to maybe try 460
actually does robinhood yeah they do
after hours
do it in 2015 the tsa collected 765
000 in loose change at airport security
checkpoints
that's cool yeah that's not three
quarters of a million dollars what is it
who
who gets to keep it the government i
don't know
really no no no that's interesting
that's cool
i wonder how much loose change there is
just on the streets right now in the
world
how many millions of dollars do you
think there are just do you think it is
the net worth of some of our no way the
wealthiest people
no i don't think some of the wealthiest
people but i think it's probably enough
to put somebody if they
got every single piece of loose change
right now sitting on the streets they
probably would be
you know up in the at least the five
percent oh yeah there's probably
there's probably tens of millions of
dollars out there right now
just unaccounted for or lost just in the
tsa alone if there's three quarters of a
million dollars
yeah just tens of millions of dollars
between the window and between the car
there's at least like a dollar yeah it's
a good place to check for loose change
yeah i'm one of those people that will
grab loose change off of a sidewalk any
day
i always grab it it's good and then it
assists my wallet and it makes my wallet
too heavy
do you do the same pick up lose change i
used to i don't i don't anymore
i don't i don't leave the house very
often to the point where i would see
loose change
is it is it like if you saw a quarter
would you pick it up yes
that's a that's a coffee yeah corduroy
wood pennies i don't pick up anymore
yeah nickels i don't pick up dimes i
would think about it
your time is worth more like you're you
sit there
you should pick it up or not you've
already and after five seconds it's like
well i've already lost
yeah i don't do coin discrimination i'll
grab any coin it's a penny it's a half a
penny i don't know
it's bad luck if the pennies face down
though yeah and also it's not
that explains a lot of my life then
because i've picked up pennies
regardless if they were face down or not
i found some really interesting
thought-provoking questions online and i
just like to hear you guys opinions on
it
when was the last time you tried
something new
um catalina we did that uh
submarine yeah that was a submarine
thing yes that was
not last weekend but the week weekend
before well we looked at
some real estate in some new places yeah
that was never tried that we tried that
new
thai place there or not it was new to us
it's not new to them but we tried
thai food there it wasn't thai it was
asian food
and i mean that in they had orange
chicken they had
pad thai and then they also had curry
so asian that counts something new
who do you sometimes compare yourself to
a lot of people who's the first that
comes
when i ask these questions i want to
hear immediately
the first thing that comes to mind joe
rogan oh i compare myself to you
and like where you were at my point in
life and where i'm at
all the time i compare myself to graham
as well
i'm not sure how many other people watch
that was literally as i
like read this question online i was
like that was like the first thing i
thought
i'm glad i'm not alone in that because i
felt really embarrassed to say that
no i i all the time and it it's it's i
don't think it's that healthy
because i think i'm doing enough in my
life but i feel bad if i'm not
yes like this okay so so for example
this morning
okay grant i work easily eight hours a
day
like i usually start working late and
then work really late into the night
but this morning i wanted to go surfing
so i went surfing but when i was surfing
i got so anxious in the water because i
was like oh my god
oh my god what if graham texts me like
it's it's could be nine o'clock and that
could be when the video's posting today
what if i'm not there what if he needs
something
like i was so anxious i was like how
could i even be surfing it is a tuesday
it's a workout yeah it's the worst day
but still like i didn't start
like working until like 10 30 but i'm
gonna work easily until like i don't
know 9 30
work day man you're not doing enough
jack do you think that you ask
enough questions or do you settle with
what you know
i ask you many questions i ask so many
questions it annoys people so no
that's good i think that's healthy to be
curious and to have wonder i think i
asked the right amount of questions
[Laughter]
just perfect i don't ask questions
unless something doesn't make sense
so i i ask questions if i need to know
something and if not then i won't ask a
question
and why do you not ask the question
because you already know the answer is
it is it because
you just don't care about it could be
either war
yeah is that what you do with me what
[Laughter]
i'm kidding no but sometimes even if i
do understand
sometimes i've noticed too people feel
really good
if you're talking to them if for example
you go on a date with somebody and
they're telling you a story
don't obnoxiously do this but kind of
interrupt their story with questions
in relation to something they said
earlier and it will really make them
feel like you're listening
so sometimes even at work when i
understand what they're asking of me
i'll kind of ask
so you mean this and this and this and
then they know i listened um
so sometimes you can kind of use that
that's charisma on command
stuff right now yeah some life hack yeah
what was your free stock that you got
from weeble
oh some two dollar stock i don't know
wait you get free stocks from weeble
yeah it's an insane wow i was thinking
robin hood i got a robin hood one
earlier yeah you get a free stock with
weeble
minimum value eight dollars they upped
the ante
is that 1600. my two free stocks got me
12
wow that's a 12 return on your 100
investment yeah so would you say that
was a
good investment to make to operate now
my robin hood link has gotten me a lot
more socks than the weeble one
yeah but weevil has the minimum value of
eight dollars so that that's
that's the bonus of that yeah robin hood
will give you stock that has a value
a value a value broad range no minimum
what does your joy look like today where
do you get your joy from today
an event conversation wait just today
yeah
exactly today what does your joy look
like today
wait what i don't really understand to
be honest i don't know what that means
like what this term what's that joy look
like today like was
what was something that was joyful today
what a specific instance in your day
that you were grateful for
graham came in to have lunch with me as
he usually does but on a salad but i was
in a meeting
and so but he so he had to leave but it
was really cute because he was very
excited to come in with his salad and
this fork to sit with me on the bed
bowling
because i work from the bed um because i
work from the bed
so he was all excited to come in there
and that made me feel really good that
he was so excited to come in and hang
out with me
that's cute yeah ramsay likes to hang
out with me
he goes i have this he has a cage that
graham got him
as a kitten but it's probably the size
for a small dog
not a small cat so i've taken it and
i've put a blanket over it
and so ramsay likes to go in there and
hang out i don't know what he does
because
most of the times i look at him he's not
sleeping but
he will come in there and they'll come
out and kind of say hi and i think it's
cute
and he likes to just go in there and
hang out with me that's that's good as
well
very joyous graham
i took took a break this afternoon for a
little bit that was nice
um the walk that we did after the walk
at not the walk not the walk the wonk
was nice but it was so smoky
um his break was showering after the
walk before he had to go off
film yeah and today was a stressful day
today wasn't
uh couldn't plan a video today
so
nice to know
[Laughter]
i found joy today i was gonna say
surfing but i was so
anxious and stressed during surfing that
i did not enjoy it very much
my moment of joy i swear to god it was
when i got out of surfing
and i got to my car and i looked at my
phone and i didn't have a text from
grandma
no i i would have been okay if you text
me okay man how's it going but like i
i was so scared the entire time you were
you were gonna text me like hey man it's
9am the video is posting
where are you or like something like
that i'm so scared
and like literally euphoria
like the fact that i wasn't oh my gosh
by the way you never mitigate whatever
you're going to say to me i want to hear
it
yeah i should i should have just as a
joke
but i don't want it but i don't want to
do that you did it today what do you
mean you did it like an
hour ago oh yeah when i walk down the
jack i'm like where are you
like we're all waiting for the podcast
why why because he told me to let him
know 30 minutes before so he could
shower
i'm like dude what like i've been trying
to call he's like oh
yeah it's funny graham likes to scare
you i try to scare grim never works
yeah you got to figure out your towels i
can i can only manage to hide my towels
for about
five to ten seconds so if i'm gonna
trick him i need to do it in the five to
ten seconds because otherwise it start
cracking up
it's possible you just gotta figure out
what your towel is yeah i really like
this question
um are you worried about doing things
right
or doing the right things doing things
right
i want to say both but this is a either
or
um i think doing the right things
i think that kind of ties into the other
one doing things right if you're doing
the right thing then you're doing things
right
i kind of i i could have figured that
you would have picked doing things right
and doing the right things
just based off of what i know you guys
what would you say
would be mine doing things right doing
the right things
really yeah doing things right i get a
lot of happiness out of it yeah
but i like i said i always feel like i i
i feel like i'm inadequate so even if i
do it right i never feel like i did it
right
so i don't get a lot of happiness right
now things right i always try to do
things right
but even if i do it doesn't grant me
that much happiness okay what grants me
happiness is
knowing that i did the right thing
because i think that is right doing
things right in my opinion is doing the
right things
okay yeah yeah so i also find that i
find
i get way more upset when i don't feel
i've done the right thing
i would agree that sometimes i get so
angry there's been times i have
definitely
done what i thought was right in the
moment and maybe it wasn't correct i
have
called people on their bs i have quite
literally
called on that on behalf of friends
because that's what i thought was right
in the moment maybe it wasn't then
but i don't regret it because i think i
would have been more upset with myself
for not doing or saying anything
that makes sense cool all right
all right you want to give us the outro
yeah thank you all so very much for
tuning into this
18th ever episode of the iced coffee
hour we really appreciate it
if you wouldn't mind follow all of our
instagram accounts i don't have a png
for your account but i will include it
first line in the description perfect
yeah like subscribe instagrams weeble
weeble what's what's there do you get a
free stock weeble
and we got to take the thumbnail so what
we should do is probably just um
pretend we're looking still in the
middle of i know
oh gotta do like a let's
get really close so with that said you
guys
thank you so much for tuning in until
next time
until next time until next time all
right
let's uh yeah let's turn this off